pleasure to see you pop up in the show
i know it was a surprise for a lot of
people um
i think you might be the person that's
been involved in mcu longest
in the show at least that we've seen so
far
um well other than paul and lizzy prop
maybe
yeah when when you did thor way back in
the day
i mean you know that the plan was like
oh is this gonna be this interconnected
universe did they say to you
well the door is always open for these
characters like did you have an idea
that this would be happening
no i i couldn't believe i was in a
marvel film to begin with uh
i think the best way to approach it and
most things and
work is like no expectations you know so
i was just so delighted to be there i
couldn't believe they brought me back
for a second film and now i can't
believe i'm in this so
anything marvel does i'm always i'm i'm
so excited to be involved
no matter what like one of the things
the fans are really latching on to with
your characters that they feel like you
are
us especially in in episode 4 where you
guys are trying to figure out
like what's going on do you do you feel
that link
does do you feel that as part of your
character i do
you know and as a person i'm very much
one of them one you know i i'm i'm a fan
of the mcu i love comic books i love
these characters and like um
the fun thing about episode four is that
darcy is the audience so even though
she's become
dr darcy lewis and she's an
astrophysicist now
um she's watching wandavision along with
the audience so
the first you know three episodes the
audience is like what is going on and
then darcy comes and she's like what is
going
on you know so it's kind of fun to be
their eyes uh in this
yeah the anticipation for the way the
story is
shifting and changing is so different in
this show than a lot of things people
have
um have experienced what is it like for
you
to be like now we're going to reveal
this now we're going to reveal that now
we're going to reveal that
right it's well you know it gets
overwhelming because
not only are there all of these
mysteries being solved but also you know
that you can't
say anything so for me at a certain
point i made the decision as an
actor to ignore everything else
so it's bad acting but i decided to just
focus on
on my stuff and what i was knowing and
not knowing so
i decided to kind of keep the mystery
for myself like even now i don't really
know what happens in the finale and that
was on purpose for myself um
because right now talking to you i can
not be lying when i say i really don't
know
which is helpful um it's cool to see the
character posters
it's cool to get like the funko pops and
stuff of like your characters and all
that
but people will look into every little
itty bitty detail
and so obviously the there are things
that you know that people do want to
know
um the biggest one about your character
poster is like the little jacket design
like people are interested in figuring
out
is this you going into the tv
world what excites you because you said
that you don't
like you try not to know everything but
what excites you about actually
knowing what people want to know well
isn't it it's so rare now to not be
given every answer
right because usually we we have our
shows and you can just watch everything
you know and that's the cool thing about
what disney plus is doing with these is
you do have to wait
and i think there's something so
rewarding and fun about that you know
it's almost like you're having this
shared experience because
back when i was young when i was young
um
you know you had to wait till 7 30 on
you know tuesday to watch your show that
you wanted to watch there was no way to
know in advance so
while it's frustrating and i know people
want answers i think there's something
really fun
um to a mystery and two trying to figure
it out and
and and looking into theories and stuff
i think it's just a uniting fun
experience for the audience and i know
it's tempting to look at spoilers
but don't because don't ruin the magic
for yourselves
that's what i say well i think
universally we're all here for
the ride so it's very cool thanks for
this great talking thank you so much for
having me
you